Now, let's see what happens in a typical
parallel program. In a typical parallel program that you
might write, you probably get a lock, and you
have, mentally, an association between that lock and the
data structures that are governed by that lock.
Or in other words, in writing your parallel program,
you decided that access to variables a and b
are governed by this lock. So if I wanted
to read or write variables a and b, I'll
get a lock and then I will mess with the
variables that are governed by this lock. Once I'm
done with whatever I want to do with these shared variables,
I'll unlock indicating that I'm done. And this is
my critical section. So within the critical section, and we're
allowed to do whatever I want on these data
structures that are governed by this particular lock, because that
is an association I as the programmer has made
in writing the parallel program. So if another processor
let's say P2 gets the same lock. It's going
to get the lock only after I release it. So
only after I release the lock, this guy can
get this lock because the semantics of the lock, it
is a mutually exclusive lock. And therefore, only one
person can have the lock at a time. And consequently,
if you look at the structure of this critical section
for P2, it gets a lock. And it is messing
with the same set of data structures that I was
messing with, over here. But, by design, we know that either
P1 or P2 can be messing with the data structure
at any point of time. And that's a guarantee that
I know comes from the fact that I designed the
pilot program. And the lock is associated with these data structures.
So, in other words, p2 is not going to access any of the data that, that
is inside this critical section until p1 releases the lock. We know this because
we designed this program, but the sc
memory model does not know about the association
between these data structures and this lock.
And, in particular, doesn't even know that memory
accesses emanating from the processor due to
this lock primitive is a different animal compared
to the memory accesses coming from the
processor as a result of accessing normal data
structures. So the cash coherence mechanism that
is provided by the system for implementing the
memory consistency model is going to be doing
more work than it needs to do because
it's going to be taking actions on every
one of these accesses, even though the coherence
actions are not warranted for these guys until
I release the lock. So what that means
is that there's going to be more overhead for
maintaining the coherence [UNKNOWN] with the SC memory
model, which means it's going to lead to
a poorer scalability of the shared memory system.
So in this particular example since P2 is not
going to access any of these data structures until P1
has released the lock there's no need for coherence action
for a and b until the lock is actually released.